[LASER SOUNDS]
SPEAKER: Whether
you're exploring
a data set for the first
time or summarizing
the findings of your
analysis to an audience,
you can use data visualization
to make large, complex data
sets easier to understand
and internalize.
On this episode of
BigQuery Spotlight,
it's all about visualizing
your BigQuery data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Data visualization
is a tool that
helps you turn your complex
data into compelling stories,
unlocking the insights that
both you and your audience
need to steer decision-making.
Using dashboards or
infographics, for example,
can help spark and
guide discussion
while the group explores
the data together.
However, data
visualization is not just
for communicating
with decision makers.
It is also an important part of
the exploratory analysis phase.
Seeing data in visual form
helps you, as an analyst,
identify patterns,
outliers, trends,
or other interesting
data points you
want to investigate further.
Choosing a data
visualization tool
comes down to
understanding your needs.
First, consider your use case.
Are you performing basic data
visualization and reporting?
Or more advanced tasks,
such as data modeling?
Secondly, you'll want
to balance the cost
of the tool against its feature
set and its learning curve.
Fortunately,
BigQuery is connected
with several
visualization tools,
including those across
the partner ecosystem.
So there's sure to be
one that's right for you.
Today, we'll introduce two
of these tools, Data Studio
and Connected Sheets.
Both give you the ability
to create quick, ad hoc data
visualizations, as well
as dashboards and reports.
Let's take a closer
look at each one.
First up, Data Studio, Google's
business intelligence and data
visualization platform that
lets you build scalable,
serverless interactive
dashboards.
Data Studio has two
main components.
The first, Explorer,
is a place for you
to quickly derive
insights from your data
during the exploratory
phase of data analysis.
It can be accessed
directly from BigQuery.
Just click Explorer in Data
Studio from your query results
page.
Data Studio will automatically
launch and create
a direct connection
to the query results.
You'll land in the
Explorer interface, where
you can create quick
visualizations through drag
and drop functionality.
On the back end, Data Studio
is creating SQL queries
in BigQuery to support your
exploration in real time.
In fact, you can also use
Explorer with a BigQuery
table itself, rather
than query results,
which means you don't need
to write any SQL at all.
Just select the table
and click Export,
and choose Explorer
in Data Studio.
The visuals you
create in Explorer
can be exported into the Reports
component of Data Studio.
Data Studio Reports
provides a canvas
for bringing together visuals
into a dashboard, report,
or infographic.
They're easy to share,
embed, and publish.
Plus, you can make them
interactive for your viewer
by adding an option to filter,
or select a date range directly
in the live report.
Data Studio is a great pick if
you want power with flexibility
and don't mind taking
a little bit of time
to get to know a new tool.
Plus, it's available for free.
If you're looking to wipe away
the learning curve pretty much
completely for you and
your collaborators,
you can do so with a second
tool, Connected Sheets.
Connected Sheets allows you
to analyze and visualize
your BigQuery data, up
to billions of rows,
directly in a Google Sheet.
So if you're a user
of Spreadsheets,
you already know all
you need to know.
You can access
Connected Sheets right
from your BigQuery table
or your query results
by clicking Explore with Sheets.
This will open up
a new Google Sheet
with a tab that has
a direct connection
to the full big query table.
Your Connected Sheet
shows a preview
of the table, which
can be explored
by sorting and filtering.
You can also reference the
connected Sheets in charts,
pivot tables, and
functions, which
then use the entire BigQuery
table in its calculations.
In order to support
these functions,
Connected Sheets runs queries
in BigQuery on your behalf.
You can manually request the
query to run by hitting Apply.
Results of those queries are
saved in your spreadsheet
for analysis and sharing.
You can also schedule data
to refresh automatically.
A quick note on availability.
Connected Sheets is a
feature available only
for G Suite Enterprise,
Enterprise for Education,
and Drive Enterprise
account customers.
I also want to mention Looker--
a data platform which is
now part of Google Cloud.
We recommend taking a
closer look at this tool,
especially if you're seeking an
enterprise-ready solution that
delivers business intelligence
capabilities, powers
operational workflows with
data, and enables organizations
to build their own
data applications.
There's a lot to learn in the
field of data visualization.
As you gain experience,
you can learn
to create more
effective visuals,
use them to tell
compelling stories,
and fine tune your
design skills.
And we hope that the
data visualization
tool will be just that--
a tool, and not any
additional mountain to climb.
Try out Data Studio
and Connected
Sheets from your own
BigQuery sandbox project.
You can connect one
of your own tables
or even a table from the
BigQuery public data sets
program.
For a refresher on how to
set up your own sandbox
and access our public
data sets, follow the link
in the description below.
If you want to learn
more about BigQuery,
check out the rest
of our playlist.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
on YouTube for
other great content.
Look out for our next episode
of BigQuery Spotlight.
And remember, stay curious.